in 1953 the world watched as a 27 year
old Queen Elizabeth was crowned in
Westminster Abbey
close behind the young Monarch her Maids
of Honor which one are you then
that one that one at the back I mean you
couldn't be nearer among them and the
highest ranking was Lady Rosemary you'll
find it all that that's terribly
old-fashioned clothes long skirts
and always hats 70 years later her
memory of the occasion just as Vivid it
was magical
it was
you know the music the color the
the whole sense of majesty was amazing
her six letters in Waiting in attendance
what's this one then rehearsal
instructions did you did you have many
rehearsals
eight it all went like the Clockwork it
was very easy in those days you know you
you drove up the Abbey park your car got
down says hello to the policeman who was
drinking a cup of tea in a little box
hello girls he said we just walked in no
Bits of Paper it was
a different world oh look what's
happened he's disappeared yes Charles
yes he's messing about looking the best
of your butt down there do you remember
seeing Prince Charles there watching
down yes that was a box with the Queen
Mother and Princess Margaret and Prince
Charles
um a few aunts and uncles I think all in
this box you could hear Prince Charles
sort of running up and down and the
Queen Mother sort of getting hold of him
and telling him to sit down but I mean
he was earlier what was he thought
yeah and of course when we got back to
to Buckingham Palace and the queen took
off uh crowd put it on the table and he
appeared and wrapped it and shot up the
passage was rescued by Jane Reed that
four-year-old is now 74 and Lady
Rosemary is advised to the king for
Saturday just be yourself Anna botting
Sky News